spring in Mark Wahlberg let's see what's
the latest movie this guy never stops
the Transformers the last night it hits
theaters next Wednesday June 21st where
are you right now right now I'm in New
York City I'm heading out of the country
today I'm on a worldwide promo tour for
transformers talk about the fifth
installment due to his historic
franchise my daughter my daughter didn't
City she wanted to come and then we were
going to try to come there but you know
she's having a bit of a lie-in she liked
to sleep till noon time now did you get
the pictures that I sent you
yeah I thought you that was a pretty fun
day different day strange day for you
and you did rap that day and your
daughter was crazy at you but I thought
you might enjoy right there I never had
more fun than I did that by doing an
interview for the end of it it was fun
yeah yeah I challenged her to a battle
to go back you know barely glanced up
from her phone her eyes and then family
was fun but didn't she lose her phone
that day didn't you take her phone away
she did - Mary - it was a good
five-month stretch where she didn't see
that thing is she more like you or your
mom or her mom oh I would say that she's
she's more like her mom but I think
everything would be better answered by
somebody oh I missed a party did you
watch the 34:30
on the Celtics and the Lakers did you
see that I know your brother didn't I
have a Phoenix I haven't seen yet but I
lived it I can't wait to see it you know
uh but I lived it you know I was keep
telling myself that that's my that's my
childhood doesn't the greatest sports of
every man that that era did you ever get
into those can you how old were you back
then
eleven twelve oh yeah babies 171 so no I
never never went to a game yeah we're
watching TV we go to the garden we would
be hanging out down there I applied
actually for a ballboy position when I
was really young never even got a
response you know I just wanted to get
whatever for
so before I could get I was going to say
they weren't going to let you in the
building as a ball boy back then yeah
where everybody did you have a decent
game back then did you even care about
playing basketball or did you just love
well I've played every day no I played
every day I mean we got we'd shovel snow
on the schoolyard you have to be able to
play ball I wore nothing but short
through many a winter and I played at
the boy's mother played on the traveling
team played pyo I mean I played a lot of
all but the gdl bought the neighborhood
basketball league when you and DiCaprio
played in Basketball Diaries news you
said he had a decent game back then but
who was better back then I was I was
better but I was also a different kind
of player you know but uh no I think I
was I could think it's fair to say that
I was a better basketball player in it
but he he still plays doesn't he I don't
know I think he had a new surgery he
used to come up to my house we had we
would have barbecues in my house every
weekend and Kevin Connolly and Chuck D
Pacheco and all those guys Vinny would
all come to my house and they'd play us
every weekend and then we'd have a
barbecue and stuff in my house and play
full court then it became that's got
bigger a bigger botanical like a pool
party after but that went on for a
couple Seles did that inspire entourage
at all we we were already kind of doing
you know Kevin it's funny because Kevin
would come to my house and then uh you
know that the whole kind of thing did
you know what really inspired it we gave
those guys wanting to uh my buddies
wanting to follow me around with a video
camera and film me and my guys and I was
like absolutely not everything to make
myself like that and then we said okay
why don't we do something scripted in
Levin I talked about then we brought
Doug Ellin and he kind of would come
come up to the house and hang out as we
play ball and all that stuff and hang
out me and all my guys and then he
started writing a pilot and then we have
been Kevin to audition for the part but
he was reluctant at first okay so this
wasn't based off I thought it was based
off you your your kind of Entourage and
yeah what me and my guys but then as we
started to put it together it was
okay you know what we wanted to do
Boston guys for finding you know four
guys that all did Boston really well was
difficult so they were like okay let's
make in New York and then the most
difficult thing was finding the guys was
believable as a star you know because if
you know you find a guy who had a movie
star qualities chances are he was
already a movie star
so we then said okay instead of finding
guys who would you know beat the crap
out of each other and be boys we hired
our Adrienne we thought AJ would be a
great part and he's kind of more of a
Leo kind of laid-back guys and then a
street guy like me so that's kind of how
the casting process and it happened but
initially yeah it was based on me my god
he said moving you know the real e
internal and all those guys oh my god
the re of course he's Mark Wahlberg
transformers the last night hits
theaters next Wednesday June 21st
back to the appearance with your
daughter are you done wrapping like you
don't debt like that's not going to
happen anymore
nope only in you're only in your studio
that's it
live when I'm feeling it you don't miss
it though now you know sometimes you
miss the freedom of you know being
irresponsible and showing up late and
not showing up at all but you know I'm
46 years old and I'm pretty lucky and
being disciplined focused and and having
a routine all those things have benefit
me quite nice itself when were you at
your guys least responsible oh you know
19 18 17 18 19 20 to 30 through the 30s
so a little Ella came into the world
oh man also fatherhood got you yeah I
mean I was disciplined when it came to
work like once I had an opportunity to
make movie I knew that I needed to be
more prepared than anybody you know so I
would I would do that but then I still
you know I could still do that and then
sleep 45 minutes and go back to work and
you know shoot another 12-hour day what
would you think anything interesting
what do you what do you think of LeBron
if LeBron ended his career in Los
Angeles for his brand how do you think
that would go over basketball community
the Clippers I'll say the Lakers ah look
I I'm a firm believer I was just talking
about Jimmy Butler today's and Celtics
you know we pick somebody in the draft
or a trade to pick to get get us a
couple of stars you know I would rather
see that a Jenny Butler Paul George
somebody coming to LA but these guys
have to go in the boss they have to go
where they want to go so I always felt I
was most comfortable Kevin Durant making
that decision to go to the water so I
you know I think LeBron is going to be
successful wherever those are whatever
he does you know in basketball and after
basketball but you know I think I get it
into business you know I'd love to see
all those does it look better in green
and yellow but I think whatever they
want to do you know it's fine I get it I
understand what are your kids are your
boys Laker fans no my son you know
they're they're Celtics fan oh um my son
like the next because he likes Carmelo
and that was his first in a mural
basketball team he played for for the
Knicks so you know he's walked around my
house with an a-rod Jersey and he can
always goes against the grain but they
all they'll alternate Lee root for the
Celtics but you know my son and the
finals is on my youngest boy he was
using for the Cavs and my wife and a man
is on one of the Warriors and they want
to KD ting in so well I can alternately
know it's all Patriots and a Celtics
baseball they have no interest did you
have a conversation with your wife after
gizelle went on the CBS Morning Show
with Charlie Rose and talked about Brady
having concussions including one this
past season because they I was at a
topic that you you would have had with
your wife of saying something public
like Giselle did about Tom oh well we
would have had a guy we didn't have a
conversation about it but we would have
definitely if that were the case a
little certain things are you know
supposed to be said but you know the
concerned wife was talking about you
know the risks to the job and we'll all
have initially would you take a
concussion so let's interrogate to a
four-game suspension benefit what'd you
give would you take a concussion for
Brady
at this stage of my life no I've had
quite a few myself and I still have
symptoms for the last well I got two
really three days at home and I hadn't
symptoms I still have a little lingering
symptom and get over a year so I
couldn't do that for Tom I offer of one
of them a so basically that for ago wait
what happened at home you got a
concussion crazy stuff I had to take the
kids electronics I put them up in my
high and then I went to jump up and lift
it and I hit my head on a chandelier and
it broke and that was I was fine I
didn't really feel any symptoms and then
three days later I was wearing in the
little boss shell for the pool and my
son came into the pool that it seemed he
so I want to go sneak up on him and I
went to dive and it's like a foot deep
of water and then it goes right up the
deep end and I caught the edge of the
cliff so I went in full of water and
then hits my head but called an
authority on the concrete and if I have
fell in the water I don't think I would
be here today but I was able to get up
and I didn't have any blood but I was
you know took a good hint and then I had
dinner take a shower we watched the
movie I went to bed I woke up four
o'clock in the morning had to go to the
bathroom and the whole room was spinning
start vomiting slowing and then was able
to lay down finally get back to bed
which I shouldn't have and then I got up
in the morning and saying things
happening to my wife trip to the
emergency room and they said I
definitely had a concussion and they not
I said if it doesn't if it doesn't you
know side in three weeks then go get the
MRI or the Cascade on her hand that I
did that I was good at that continue to
happen that I'm going to Steve Tisch
concussion center at UCLA and the doctor
basically did the same with release of
calcium so they in shipment in the major
in there and I think that's that I don't
know his fingers are they I'm going to
like mark apartments and a great pic I
get like a little business or a little
flash and I can 2004 Tommy
another do be there for my kids many
others were know what I had to do it
well we hope to cross paths with you
again and certainly with with l2 she was
a very entertaining good luck with the
movie safe travels as always
thanks for making time you're the best
buddy thank that hi that's a mark Wilbur
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience